Sandra is in Pittsburgh hey Sandra
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
I have a question may my husband are
having a little bit of disagreement on
we are finishing baby step three this
month and we will be certain baby step
four
he makes around seventy thousand a year
I make twenty four times
mine is a mandatory seven and a half
they take automatically I had to do that
through the baby steps could you Clinton
quit it now he's saying he needs to take
a his no mass update percent and he says
eight that'll make our fifteen but I'm
not agreeing with that I think how math
works yeah here's eight percent of his
income and seven percent of your income
does not equal fifteen percent of our
household income you don't add those
together that's going to be more like
seven and three-quarters percent of our
household income okay you take the
number that is coming out of your check
going into retirement divide that into
your income and that will give you the
percentage you're at about half of what
you should be okay okay ninety-five let
me tell you it should be around fifteen
thousand dollars a year for you guys
fifteen thousand a year okay yeah
because I was figuring on taking what we
make the total actually here one five
times 0.15 that's fifteen percent right
and so a hundred thousand times 0.15
household income is fifteen thousand
that's where I got that okay you guys
are making 90 so it's going to be 14 7
or 14 five or something right and so you
know that that's where you're going to
be and yeah you don't get to add 8
percent of his income and 7 percent of
your income for that to be equal 15
that's not how the math works okay that
makes sense yeah I think any person of
your household income annually going
into retirement and that's maybe step
four you know we're not trying to figure
out how little we can do we're trying to
figure out how much we can do because
the more we do the more money we have
okay this is how fast I build wealth not
how slow I build wealth yeah
now he was just thinking the eight and
the seven I said no because I make less
than you yeah it's not even that it's
not they don't add together they are of
each and take the total times 15 and
you're gonna see it's a whole lot more
money than you're talking about like I'm
doubling what you're talking about
yes oh definitely yeah you're doubling
like yeah so then you do we do like
mine's a mandatory 750 bucks a month
coming out of somebody's checks
[Music]
somewhere total yeah but that's you know
yes so add add to yours add to his I
don't care if you put it all on his and
maybe your retirement plan sucks but as
long as the total is 15 percent of 90
then we're okay and the way you do that
is 0.15 times the whole thing